first offense efficiency game
the other night and coincidentally they
had their best on defense here's a.d
and one off the window to start things
off over his last 12 before he hit that
one the downtown russ working inside
with the left hand
as a freshman
before he
moved around a little bit in high school
avery bradley on the way under the bra
to finish it two very high-paced teams
early on in this nba season the rockets
and the lakers
russ goes into a little bit of a dance
he's going to attack the rim throws it
up and in with the left hand
he looks like a superhero out there i've
been growing up watching him and all
right he's got one game under his belt
as davis just alone at the rim plays it
down with two hands 15 total points in
all the other games combined for avery
russell looks to attack the rim again
boy he looks to see his creativity off
the dribble
i mean he's a completely different
player tonight
davis
slam dunk lakers give the assist to
brawn
it's a three on one reeves tried to take
the charge and he might have altered the
shot three on one davis love lebron
finish it
lob under the christian wood pretty good
defense that time by 80 but you're right
after he made that play hobbling on one
leg lacrosse
two hands emphatic dunk oh
whoa
lebron
made the play on one end and then
finished on the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
porter jr once again going into a dance
nice move dips in comes out that went in
a little heartbreak for him russ with
some speed in the attacking 47 all the
way spins it up and scores dude in
trouble now with one on the shot clock
augustine can't hit makers three on one
westbrook all the way lebron finish it
lbj
[Applause]
lebron going to work
right when he needs to and lebron with
the basketball
head down head up here he goes left hand
got it again wow lebron james in charge
that was deshawn tate case john jay
blocked that time by wood now it's a.d
cleaning up
out of bounds which is what it would
have been
lebron
trying to put an end to this mess
and he scores not an end to it but add
to it as he puts him back up